bonjour nouveau numéro de check-up le
magazine santé de la rédaction de tvfils
78 ce mois-ci nous parlons du Trophée de
l'impertinence reçu par là CPAM des
Yvelines d'une maladie génétique
répandue pourtant mal connue les mots
chromatose à travers le témoignage d'un
jeune chrétien des bienfaits du chi kong
une gymnastique traditionnelle chinoise
mais d'abord le premier sujet qui nous
intéresse c'est la cigarette
électronique ses ventes augmente elle
fait de plus en plus d'adeptes de des
boutiques ouvre comme ici à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pourtant
est-ce que c'est l'arme efficace pour
arrêter de fumer c'est ce que nous avons
voulu savoir
la cigarette électronique fait un tabac
depuis 2010 les enseignes se développent
leur nombre devrait même doubler cette
année pour atteindre 300 le matériel en
tout ça m'a coûté de 83 euros en sachant
que je fumais un paquet de cigarettes
par jour ce qui faisait 42 euros par
semaine donc en deux semaines j'aurai
rentabilisé ma cigarette électronique
dans la pratique le fumeur aspire sur la
cigarette électronique comme il le
ferait avec une vraie mais ne l'allume
pas elle ne produit pas de fumée mais de
la vapeur d'eau absorbée par les poumons
c'est la cartouche jetable ou e-liquide
qui contient la nicotine et les arômes
qui vont du goutaba authentique à des
saveurs plus insolites
abricot les marques françaises 10
liquides ont du mal à suivre les
commandes des boutiques spécialisées on
recherche en tout cas sur l'Union
européenne des nouveaux fournisseurs en
espérant qu'il y ait des nouvelles
marques qui fabriquent en France parce
que on aimerait bien rester sur ce label
français ce qui est sûr c'est que il y a
beaucoup de produits qui sont fabriqués
en Chine patron ne veut pas vendre ses
produits chinois reste approuvé
scientifiquement les notions
d'efficacité et de risques de la
cigarette électronique probablement que
c'est certainement beaucoup moins
dangereux il n'y a pas de monoxyde de
carbone il n'y a pas de goudron il y a
tous les produits qui sont fabriqués par
la combustion n'existe plus mais dire
que c'est un produit non dangereux pour
l'instant on ne peut pas le dire puisque
ça il manque des études et une
connaissance de la composition exacte de
ces produits lit-cigarette séduit
aujourd'hui près d'un million de fumeurs
selon le docteur dosenberg il vient de
publier un rapport avec 21
recommandations comme l'interdire dans
les lieux publics après faudrait
vraiment l'argumenter pour voir s'il y a
une nocivité pour les notamment les
passifs mais
enfin moi je comprends pas trop enfin ça
sent rien ça voilà ça il y a plus de
gêne normalement l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé estime que d'ici 2020 le
tabagisme sera la principale cause de
décès et d'incapacité avec plus de 10
millions de victimes par an
voilà et puis depuis ce reportage à
ministre de la Santé Marisol le Touraine
à annoncé vouloir appliquer aussi
les mêmes restrictions que celles qui
existent pour le tabac allez un trophée
de l'impertinence décerné à la CPAM des
Yvelines mais oui ça existe une
récompense décernée pour le dispositif
santé actif qui en ce mois de juin fête
son premier anniversaire dans le
département explication
le dispositif fait son premier
anniversaire à Poissy couronné d'un
trophée de l'impertinence ce n'est pas
une start-up qui l'a reçue mais la
Caisse Primaire d'Assurance Maladie pour
ses ateliers sentait active des ateliers
réservés aux assurés uniquement en bonne
santé pour prévenir au lieu de guérir
autour de trois thématiques le dos le
cœur et la nutrition aux commandes
Patrick negaret ce directeur atypique a
lancé le premier atelier en France il y
a 15 ans et depuis la exporter dans 8
départements les dépenses consacrées à
la prévention sont très faibles par
rapport aux dépenses consacrées aux
soins c'est en ça que ça contre courant
parce qu'on a très souvent prédécision
énergiques de réduction de dépenses
d'augmentation des recettes on n'a
jamais pris des actions sur un plus long
terme les affections chroniques croisent
constamment c'est les 8 dixièmes de
l'évolution c'est les deux tiers des
dépenses c'est un point considérable et
rembourser des soins c'est une bonne
chose mais finalement l'objectif d'une
caisse c'est plutôt de vous assurer sur
la bonne santé c'est ça l'idée d'origine
de la sécurité sociale
favorise l'accès aux soins c'est pour
que les gens soient bonne santé l'enjeu
est de taille dans les Yvelines les
dépenses de santé s'élèvent à 2,7
milliards d'euros d'autres sites santé
actives vont voir le jour le 19 juin à
Versailles en plein centre-ville et à la
fin de l'année à Guyancourt boulevard
Vauban c'est gratuit ouvert en semaine
jusqu'à 19h et même le samedi prochaine
étape un service sur Internet tout le
monde peut pas se déplacer tout le monde
le souhaite pas se déplacer non plus et
à l'époque on est sur internet on peut
gagner à la fois d'efficacité en coût et
les gens chez eux disposeront finalement
d'un coaching en ligne via le compte
ameli à compter de l'automne le site de
Poissy compte 1000 personnes inscrites
en France 20 000 assurés ont déjà suivi
le mouvement la moyenne d'âge est de 45
ans et ce sont en majorité des femmes
savez-vous ce qu'est les mots chromatose
ce nom ne vous dit peut-être rien et
pourtant c'est une maladie génétique
répandue qui se caractérise par un excès
de fer dans le sang nous avons rencontré
Gwenaëlle Benard c'est un jeune clecien
qui a découvert sa maladie il y a deux
ans témoignage
13,8
tous les trois mois Gwenaëlle Benard se
rend à l'Établissement français du sang
au Chesnay aujourd'hui on lui prélève
450 ml un traitement unique et
indispensable pour sa pathologie car le
jeune homme est atteint des mots
chromataux c'est-à-dire un excès de fer
dans le sang c'est la première maladie
génétique de France j'étais pendant un
peu plus de trois mois où je dormais
très peu et très mal donc à force de
voir des médecins et finalement le
médecin de famille qui est de Bretagne
qui a eu l'idée de faire analyser mon
fer et c'est là qu'on a découvert que
j'avais un taux de ferritine très élevé
on n'a pas trouvé mieux parce que ça ça
dit bien ce que ça veut dire
les symptômes peuvent être trompeurs
forte fatigue douleurs musculaire
trouble sexuel signe de diabète ou
encore faible densité osseuse la maladie
chez les femmes se déclare plutôt à la
ménopause en France une personne sur 300
est porteuse du gène déficient
comment améliorer le déplacement des
personnes âgées ou des personnes en
situation de handicap c'est sur cette
question qu'on plancher des élèves
ingénieurs de l'ESTACA ils ont présenté
leurs travaux à l'occasion d'un colloque
qui s'est tenu à la Faculté des sciences
de la santé
comment améliorer les déplacements des
personnes à mobilité réduite d'abord en
organisant l'espace urbain à 50 ans en
Yvelines par exemple sur 400 km de
voirie
16082 obstacles précisément ont été
recensés ensuite en proposant de
nouvelles technologies des étudiants et
des chercheurs de l'ESTACA école
d'ingénieurs qui viendra s'implanter à
Montigny dans deux ans ont présenté leur
production lors d'un premier colloque à
l'image de ce tricycle qui peut se plier
en mode déambulatoire un travail étalé
sur trois mois la difficulté était que
le tricycle correspondent aux dimensions
du quai des charges afin que on puisse
utiliser pour passer dans des portes ou
pour aller au supermarché c'est surtout
ça la grande difficulté c'est un peu un
projet qui est très proche un projet
professionnel donc c'est ce qui était
intéressant parce que on était en sorte
un peu des études on pouvait enfin
penser à un produit qui pourrait
peut-être être vendu plus tard autre
projet le développement d'une assistance
électrique pour fauteuil roulant fournir
une assistance un fauteuil roulant quand
on pousse on sent qu'on est un petit peu
aidé et quand on recule on sent qu'on a
un petit peu aidé aussi donc
effectivement d'un point de vue
fonctionnel c'est pas forcément pas être
très compliqué après quand on rentre
dans les détails il s'agit de faire une
mesure d'effort rien qu'une mesure
d'effort c'est pas forcément quelque
chose qui est évident ce qui fait la
complexité d'un projet comme celui-là
c'est un peu le
moment où on regroupe toutes les briques
qu'on a vu en cours voilà et puis le
temps aussi qui fait que c'est ses cours
et c'est voilà c'est ce qui fait que les
projets sont intéressants des
innovations présentées en partenariat
avec le Centre d'études sur la mobilité
et le handicap le CRM a été développé
dans le cadre du pôle de compétitivité
Moveo implantée à Versailles les
problèmes posés par les personnes de la
mobilité réduite sont son source de
réflexion qui peuvent amener à la au
développement de produits de services
qui en plus sont rendre service au grand
public également mais pour acquérir ces
innovations technologiques qu'il faudra
faire preuve de patience au moins trois
ou quatre ans
logic-kong ou gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise une association de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux propose
régulièrement des séances c'est la page
bien-être de ce magazine soyons zen
les mouvements de chi kong sont amples
doux l'enchaînement harmonieux quasi
poétique
cette gymnastique traditionnelle
chinoise associée gestuelle lente et
posture physique respiration et travail
du souffle concentration et conscience
corporelle elle requiert des principes
de base
l'enracinement la fluidité
l'humidité du corps le vide le plein le
Yin le yang ces élèves ont tenu
décontractés maîtrisent les
enchaînements et semble ainsi hors du
temps et juste après le cours je me sens
en pleine forme j'ai envie
d'entreprendre plein de choses j'ai
beaucoup récupéré je me sens
très en accord avec ce qui m'entoure
aussi quand j'en ai besoin je le
pratique à la maison ou dans la nature
et en fait ça devient une hygiène de vie
en fait et un bonheur les visages comme
les corps apparaissent détendus
paisibles cette discipline ancestrale
les mêmes pour ses bienfaits sur
certains mots beaucoup de rigidité
beaucoup de problèmes
de liaison entre les différentes parties
du corps beaucoup de problèmes
rhumatismaux on a la surprise de voir
des personnes arrivées finalement très
handicapés et en quelques séances on les
voit réussir des exercices dont on se
demande si ce sont vraiment les mêmes
personnes qu'on avait vu quelques
semaines auparavant
avant de nous quitter vous en avez
l'habitude on va jeter un coup d'oeil
sur l'agenda santé du mois pour rompre
l'isolement des personnes
âgées pendant les vacances le Conseil
général met en place ce dispositif
Yvelines étudiant senior sont des
étudiants qui viennent régulièrement
visiter les personnes âgées donc pendant
l'été le 14 juin date importante à
retenir c'est la Journée nationale du
don du sang en France il y a 350 points
de collecte réguliers dans le
département peut notamment donner votre
sang au centre de transfusion sanguine
du Chanel au centre est ouvert tous les
jours voilà chez Cap c'est fini merci de
votre attention rendez-vous le mois
prochain d'ici là portez-vous bien